Oppenheimer will be drawing inspiration
from a book American Prometheus the
Triumph and tragedy of J Robert
Oppenheimer in his review of the book
James buckin wrote Oppenheimer was
haunted by Hiroshima and came to believe
that the Japanese were already
essentially defeated Oppenheimer
campaigns to push the atomic Genie if
not back into the bottle at least into
International control witnessing the
first test of History's deadliest weapon
oppenheimer's mind recalled a scripture
from the bhagavad-gita
now I am become death
the destroyer of worlds Additionally the
inclusion of Gene tatlock a former
girlfriend and Mistress of oppenheimer's
only complicates things further it makes
it all a perfect representation of the
scientists personal life lead actor
Killian Murphy collaborated a bit saying
I'm interested in the man and what
inventing the atomic bomb does to the
individual these contradictory
characters are Fascinating People
identify with that because we all walk
around with these contradictory ideas
co-existing in our heads